say where i don't need to go back to
without like alienating anybody it's pr
it's probably that's what we do here
that's our brand probably fine because i
don't think anybody who is born there
stays israel
well i can't right now
i just uh i fall on the other side of
that no uh
uh portland
you're not alone
i found portland oregon to be like i was
all psyched for it people were like
you're gonna love it and then i got
there and i was like what am i gonna
love about this like they hate me if you
don't like
love
like waiting for coffee for like 45
minutes yeah like they get to it when
they get if you're gonna do portland the
portland way i was dating someone lived
in portland for like two years i would
go up there all the time and i remember
being like i get to like rewrite i'm off
on script i have a month to write a
script i'm like what do people do that
have jobs you order a coffee they're
making it like they're dripping it money
doesn't make anything go round the guy's
like doing finishing his hacky sack game
and you're like can i just get my coffee
like who has this time i had a
conversation reporting legit we landed
on a sunday and i went out and like the
town was like
toast nothing was open on a sunday yeah
and i was like it's religious or
something so i was like asking the
coffee shop like it seems kind of dead
and like yeah sundays are really
different aspergers so like sundays are
really dead people go out pretty hard on
saturday so sundays are kind of it's
like oh so they close the stores yeah a
lot of them yeah it's like well
do you think this place will be open
tomorrow like monday is kind of like
monday's kind of tough it's like kind of
like a second sunday
and i was like
well then wouldn't it be sun
do they work did people work he's like
yeah people work but it's like
tough i was like what about tuesdays
like tuesday second monday i was like
what is this fucking city like it's
everyone home but this is a store i'm
out of store i need you here brick and
mortar
open the door
i need like beaded stacks yeah like
where is just money money doesn't matter
in portland people truly are like i'll
get to it when i get to it but yeah i
mean i i mean fred arminson and kerry
brownstein did such an amazing job i
feel like of uh
satirizing portland but it is so funny
how
um
not exaggerated that one is no in fact
like i find i found it to be almost like
reality in a lot of ways like stuff
would outshine it like you know like a
store where there's birds on everything
like that's almost like boring for
portland now yeah yeah yeah like
portland's like no no everything's a
bird yeah yeah yeah
like what it's like no the table's made
out of bird bones it's like this is a
bird this is a bird you're in a
bird you know we're all birds he's like
we're all starting
it's like oh cool how's the business
doing terribly
terrible we make no money it's like well
how do you afford this amazing things
like that we don't know this is there's
no water electricity it's like we don't
know what's going on what happens if
something bad happens can i call the
police they don't work
like what happens if the thing goes on
fire it's like run because there's no
fire department
no paramedics
and weed caused a dime weed is so cheap
the best part about it is they think
you're trash oh they
you're disgusting someone yelled at me
to go back to california i was like
that's anti-semitic okay
that is i
i'm not from california
you're saying that because you think
there's a camera following me and you
think i'm a hollywood jew
so like go back to california but i'm
not from california because they like
didn't want filming in their cities yes
and they were like we were like when i
think about people from portland i think
you guys want no attention yeah that's
what i have when i look at your eyes
meanwhile the guy has like gauges
through every orifice why are you
rolling up your jeans this to an inch is
there a flood coming is it because i
cannot fuck you if i picture you rolling
two rolls and so i can see yourself i
don't know how anyone fucks in portland
yet there's like um dearth of strip
clubs
like you can't walk in portland without
like if you're on your phone looking
down you're like i'm so sorry you look
up it's like someone on nine inch
stilettos with like they all have like
thrown out like armpit hair and like
c-section scars no they all look like an
american apparel it's like all like
suicide girl like american apparel like
yeah old thing and you like well
everyone's like everyone's just like
walking from one strip club to another
there's like one strip club that's vegan
and one that's me and they're across the
street from each other it's like the
whole thing i was just like
i don't know like it feels kind of like
yeah it's a lifestyle yeah it felt too
much like that to me where other cities
it's also that part of portland is very
small i mean that like pearl district
area it is like
10 blocks it's like less than downtown
and then it's just a downtown city yeah
yeah it's it's truly a weird it's also
they don't have hotels they don't want
you coming there there's no nice hotel
there's no nice they don't the nines is
great but
it's you know they don't want people
coming there they don't have hotels for
you and there's no and when you do go to
the hotel it's like
bare bones it's like what do we do here
it's like well wine comes at six and
that's when that's when we take off
you're like the hotel takes off like at
six
like there's just like no
it's europe it feels like no supervision
it like it feels like everybody like the
dorks took over yeah there's no problem
yes there's like all the cool kids went
to california
so all like the raging dorks are like
don't come in here
no girls allowed there's my tree yeah
like oh no you can't come in here unless
you're dressed like a forger
we make all our silverware ourselves and
if you can't get down with that go back
to california
i was just like all right i'm going back
to the company by the way because it's
also the men the boots they all wear are
it's the one brand red wing the red wing
boots
they're the platforms are literally two
inches all the men are just in heels
it's like they short guys can wear heels
and it's like no but i'm a lumberjack we
went to a bar like shooting they were
like
when i was dating the guy every bar was
downstairs down a flight of stairs
this was like uh we went to a bar down a
flight of stairs and everyone's like
this is gonna be so funny this is gonna
be great it's gonna be so funny and it
was an
old it was a mead house like mead like
like from like notebooks
of the notebook uh no like you need like
mead like our
you got our cup of mead
like is that like ale yes but like it's
even gross it's
and and everybody was dressed as like a
lord of the rings like
you know and everyone's like sitting
down everyone's in character everyone's
like it wouldn't point to me it's the
renaissance fair and i was like what is
this like fucking hell it is literally
cosplay like this is so fun so funny
they put down like the big thing of mead
it's vomit
[Laughter]
you know what portland is
it is
adults larping yeah i i felt it was like
it had big divorce energy
because like when people get divorced
sometimes they like they're like you
know what that was the old me
you know that was carter when carter was
married to rebecca but the new carter
doesn't even like pickleball
the new carter the noob carter pickles
watermelon yeah the new carter is doing
it all from the earth
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Applause]